help for instagram users who are
concerned about their privacy you might
have seen posts like this making the
rounds on social media it claims that an
iphone update which allows app users to
use precise location tracking also makes
it easier for criminals to find and
target instagram users now in a twitter
post instagram says that's not true the
company says quote we don't share your
location with others adding that the app
uses the precise location function for
accurate tags and map features but if
you don't want apps like instagram
tracking your precise location we're
going to show you right now how to turn
it off
first open up your phone's iphone
settings
type in instagram and click on the apps
icon you're going to see the specific
settings there right
finally hit the location button
and then slide to the precise location
function
and hit that button turn off the precise
location right boom right there turn it
off done you can also change your
location access to never so the app
doesn't track your location even if
you're using it
that's amazing that's interesting i knew
mine was on never but now i want to look
and see if i did the precise look i
looked and mine was on so i turned it
off i didn't know there was that lower
one i've gotta never you know if if
instagram had like a team of guys with
clipboards following you down the street
you'd be really weirded out
that's pretty much what they're doing
pretty much what they're doing and the
reality is some some people don't care
they honestly most people almost prefer
it yeah most people that i've talked to
and i've covered this for years they
just don't care as long as they're
getting a better user experience that's
the bottom line okay i turned it off